I won I'm Felix vice and how many of you
use Visual Studio code clearly quite a
few yeah it's it's a great tool
Microsoft obviously has done a lot of a
lot of work and one of the things that's
exciting as she saw it just maybe yeah
yesterday you may have seen it in the in
the Python weekly email that they now
support Jupiter notebooks natively in
the English studio code and so I wanted
to quickly show this of course having no
preparation and I need to figure out
well what do I actually show and that I
can show other and that's not some work
at work that I shouldn't be shown here
so I took a presentation I gave earlier
this year at our in the PI meetup where
I actually at the time for the
presentation really the goal was to show
how to use how to build a flask in
docker to how easy that is and then as
an example actually showed how to build
a OCR server with tesseract that and put
a REST API in front of it and then call
it from the Jupiter notebook
and so now here I turn it around and
just show the true Patino book so this
is running in Visual Studio code it
actually true Buddha notebook actually
obviously the code runs the true poodle
server so you don't you can't connect to
one remotely that's zero a running local
running on the machine or or remote
remote but it actually starts one itself
as necessary so here without show here
is how I'm talking it's starting this so
sweet it started the server and
obviously executed it's the first cell
and so here I connect to Milan to a log
server using and then use the requests
to send images and get back the result
so let's do this here so I have an image
that are loaded and that plotted so you
can see here it does that all in line so
get the output in line and so this is
the image we'll we'll try to do some
asiago so run it here and I get back the
result now a few things to show here is
first of all you can see visual studio
code actually lets you see the local
variables or the variables that are in
that kernel so you can and here
obviously not very exciting ones in
addition though I can take if I'm at an
image here for example I can open that
in a separate in a separate tab zoom in
look at it more closely
but whether but it does get interesting
let's see if you have graphs that's for
data more interesting so let's go here
because what I'm showing here is what
happens if the image is not actually
straight and this is also a server
doesn't really like that so showing how
you can turn though or so here I'm doing
a graph with a histogram of the pixels
and you can see here if I again if I can
look at this more closely directly in
the in in the English studio code as you
obviously those of you familiar with
Troopa notebooks that's quite a bit of
now in addition if it's actually a
panda's data frame or in this case a
[Music]
numpy array you can actually drill down
into it it has a data viewer where you
can then even filter on rows
for example show me everything that's
less than twenty directly in without
having to do in a cell with a with the
data frame dot whatever range and I
think I'm out of time
yes pardon that's neither a Beth's
that's natively supported by Visual
Studio code now so this is all just
again I just saw this yesterday played
with a little bit and this is and they
will support debugging locally in the
individual cells that's what they're
working on visit yeah no this is again I
literally just open a port pulled sync
to my github repo and open the notebook
in in in the pseudo code and it just it
you can see it actually you saw it it
launched the kernel over there this is
server and and locally connected to it
yeah so for example let's see if I here
ever see IMG I thought that at least it
did it when I tried it last time so
it'll it'll so we can Auto completion
and intellisense
[Music]